namibia is a land of dramatic contrasts
the namib desert from which it gets its
name is known as the oldest desert in
the world
our vehicle looks tiny in comparison to
the rolling sand dunes
and they border the atlantic coast for
hundreds of kilometers
while in the northeast of the country is
the kavango caprivi strip
a stark contrast because of its humid
subtropical climate
which makes it home to abundant wildlife
you don't have to go far along the
kavango river before
feasting your eyes on animals in their
natural environment
the rivers a crucial source of water in
this semi-arid country
it discharges into the okavango delta
considered one of africa's most valuable
ecosystems
and the area also encompasses the
migration route
for the world's largest remaining herd
of savannah elephants
[Music]
now many living across this huge stretch
of land fear the delicate natural
balance
could all be at risk namibia is one of
the hottest emerging areas for oil and
gas exploration
a canadian company called recon africa
believes there's one of the world's
biggest oil fields hiding below we
expect to confirm the existence
of a working hydrocarbon system sky's
the limit for this company
when we do that the company says it
conducted a high-resolution geomagnetic
survey of the untested kavango basin
and they believe billions of barrels of
crude oil are waiting to be found
we have analyzed data from virtually
every
sedimentary basin around the world we
have never seen a sedimentary basin
with this depth or this size that hasn't
produced
vast quantities of hydrocarbons
they've bought oil exploration licenses
for thousands of kilometers
stretching across namibia and
neighboring botswana
the marwano family now live in the
shadow of a massive exploratory oil
drill
it's in what used to be their backyard
land they say was given by village
elders
and was once filled with cops and
livestock
andreas moana took us through his small
field of maze to show us what's there
now
i'm powerless he told us i cannot do
anything
[Music]
our drone pictures show how close his
family huts are to the well now being
drilled
to discover if there's oil beneath
but andreas and his family are poor
they've hardly any money for food
never mind fighting any legal battle
is i can't afford a lawyer he says who
will help me stand up against this oil
company
his family like so many around here live
simply
and community leaders believe poverty
has made them invisible
my feeling to them they are not
considered as human being
because their human right is not
considered
yeah that is why they are treating them
like
they are not a human being
many of the nearby villagers who we
spoke to felt the same
saying they hadn't been properly
consulted
recon africa insists they carried out
numerous consultation sessions directly
in the community
but the villagers told us they had a
string of worries
many of them survive by growing their
own vegetables and rely on the land
i worry too because the things the oil
they are doing
we don't know what the effect of that
oil and our
environment we are afraid for that
we grow these vegetables in the ground
she says if our ground is destroyed
how will we sow it again will the soil
still be able to grow these vegetables
if they find oil
and like andreas they too are living on
land
bequeathed to them by traditional
leadership
hundreds of kilometers away it's a
different world
but the village's concerns are shared
you heard those elephants
just in here environmentalists fear
any disturbance in this sensitive eco
area will have a detrimental impact
on the wildlife particularly the
elephants
they're shy animals especially alert to
sound
and vibration and already at risk from
shrinking territory and poachers
[Music]
we went to one of the elephant's
favorite watering holes to find out just
how far they traveled
this nut the tree that it grows on
doesn't exist here
100 kilometers away is the closest tree
approximately
so this nut was eaten 100 kilometers
away
and traveled here in the intestines of a
an elephant and deposited here for us to
find
namibia's waterways are crucial it's the
driest country in sub-saharan africa
this is what you could call the start of
the occupancy delta and these
waters are a lifeblood for tens of
thousands of people
countless wild animals and a huge amount
of vegetation
it is a lifeline to a desert delta and
if
anything should happen to these waters
it will have a catastrophic impact
on multiple countries
it's up to us to protect it and if we
don't
it'll be good paint the water you'll
taint all the wildlife
any intervention of man in this area
will change its wildness
in any form and we'll bring more people
we'll bring more traffic we'll bring
more pollution we'll bring more noise
and so the wildlife will be diminished
and the beauty
and pure nature that's here will be
harmed in some way many believe the
pandemic restrictions
meant consultation about the oil
exploratory project
was greatly hampered and some go further
a corona lockdown state of emergency for
six months
was used as a shield and a cover in
order for them to get permission
that there isn't any public
participation let's rush things through
let's get things going before too many
people know and see
but the company says they've tried to
keep a collaborative relationship with
all the interested parties and carried
out a full environmental
impact assessment before the pandemic
lockdown
up north the drill site cuts a dramatic
scar in the midst of acres and acres of
bush
there is substantial poverty in the
kovanga basin where the site is
and recon africa has provided a few
extra boreholes to help the villagers
the area's traditional hedman told us
the profits from any oil discovery
would transform the area and provide
much needed jobs
and only the privileged would see it
otherwise
you educated people who already have
comfortable lives
you want to restrict development here
that means we
will stay poor and probably die poor
the oil company insists it has a history
of environmental care
and doesn't intend to do any fracking
which environmentalists blame for
contaminating groundwater
while the namibian government emphasizes
oil has yet to be discovered
our filming at the site soon attracted
the attention of the workers
but they were reluctant to answer any
difficult questions
this is andreas he actually
lives on this land and and he feels that
you've camped illegally on this
i'll get your information to the right
person okay would you like to say
anything to him
for andreas and the other villagers
around here there seems little recourse
since this interaction recon africa told
us they're trying to address his
concerns
but there's still growing anxiety about
villagers land rights
and their ability to farm and what any
oil discovery would do to one of the
most beautiful
and unspoiled places left in the world
alex crawford sky news namibia